[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well he's the dolphins quarterback and
the dolphins quarterback of the future
he's two at tonga vialoa who's back on
the program good morning tua what did
you think of the
matthew stafford trade
good morning dan thank you guys for
having me um
yeah i i don't know too much about how
these trade deals work
um you know but i i think whatever
you know i think the two organizations
you know
pretty much got what they wanted i i
don't know too much
else about those things where are you
right now
i'm at home i'm in my office at home is
that your bedroom
no no no this is my office what do you
got in there you got uh
some some trophies there behind you yeah
i do well what's the one that if you had
to get out of the house you'd grab
um
i'm not too sure i
i probably grab the football what's the
football
is that the national title game no that
was my first touchdown
uh throw in the nfl oh cool that's good
uh now is that where you get the
touchdown receiver gives it to you and
then you hand it to
like the uh equipment guy correct okay
yes
correct uh where are you gonna watch the
super bowl
i'll be at home watching the super bowl
got any uh
are you leaning afc since you're an afc
guy
man i i just hope to see a really good
game
that's that's really all it is you know
whoever wins um
wins i think you know there's two really
good
quarterbacks but then you also got two
really good defenses
uh as well so i just want to see a good
game
you think you'll be playing quarterback
at 43 in the nfl
i mean god bless tom that's that's crazy
that's crazy i you know god willing that
my
my career is that long if not you know
i'd hope to at least have a decent
career
i asked this to uh justin herbert last
week i i said
take away i'm gonna let you take away
one defender on the chiefs defense like
you're gonna play them and you know that
guy
doesn't get to play because you said
that he doesn't get to play
who would that guy be
uh who would that guy be
you know i i think it's hard to just
pick out one guy
because studying their defense
i mean these guys are multiple defense
they
you know first and second down are
normally downs where
you understand or you can you kind of
know what the
defense is going to give you third down
is when they switch it up but
for the chiefs you know they they do
what they do on third down on first
second third and fourth down
you know you just never know what you're
gonna get with them
i just think it's very hard to pick out
one guy
herbert said uh tyron matthew
tyrants really good too uh but you know
when
when they're when they're pressuring you
know and
i mean it it just really makes it hard
how many times how many times did you go
to the line of scrimmage at alabama
and know it was going to be a touchdown
uh i would say
a little over 50 percent
a little over 50 um wow
yeah and then sometimes you know with
the short passes
i just thought it'd be you know at least
a decent catch and run
um but a lot of the times you know i i'd
get the
fall in the hands of jerry or devonta or
jalen
you know a little two-yard catch would
turn into a 72-yard
touchdown be honest with me if i was the
quarterback at alabama and i had those
receivers how many touchdowns do you
think i could throw
oh man you'd be able to throw however
many touchdowns your heart desires i
think
so so if i said i could throw 20
touchdowns behind that line
that running back that coach those
receivers i mean that's not far-fetched
for a guy who's in his 60s right
okay thank you i appreciate that he's uh
two at tonga vialoa joining us on the
program
uh what do you miss most most about
coach saban
um i mean there's there's a lot of
things to
to talk highly about coach saban um but
i think the
the one thing people don't know is the
kind of person he is off the field
he's very soft-spoken very
tender-hearted
very loving and you know very caring of
a person off the field
no one would expect that from someone
like coach saban because
when they see him coaching he
he's just another person he's yelling at
someone he's screaming at refs
you know so i don't know there's there's
a lot of memories that i have with
uh what about will you not miss
about coach saban
see i don't know i i i would say you're
playing with fire there because
in order to miss you know his his you
know
who he is off the field um you know you
got to accept who he is on the field
before you
you can really appreciate who he is off
the field um
you know because you know without
you know the pushing and whatnot you
wouldn't
you wouldn't um oh you said respect him
the same way you do because he expects
the best out of you
update me on your health of where you
were in september
to say now like
how is there a big difference in how you
feel mobility
all of that from september to to
i now say there is a big difference um
you know and then the past offseason uh
it's really
it's really been a rehab a year last
year
uh but this year i would i'd say my
my health has gotten a little better uh
but it's not something that
you know you feel is good and you just
stop um
you know working on mobility and whatnot
it's a continuing process for me
but you know we look back and we didn't
even know if your career was going to
continue
when you looked at that injury and
that's why i didn't know
if the bar was set higher because maybe
justin herbert's success
where we were expecting or joe burrow
like hey two you got to put up these
numbers
but they didn't go through what you went
through uh
was the media fair to you in the
expectations
i would i wouldn't i would say i
wouldn't
know too much because i i never never
paid attention too much to the media
with what
they had said or you know with what was
going on
really the only time i'd ever understand
uh you know about the hype
was when i got interviewed you know by
the media
um for the miami dolphins
but as far as expectations i have really
high expectations for myself
and i didn't meet those expectations
this past year
what's it like to hear your name or have
people tell you
that your name's involved in possible
trade talks with dushan watson
yeah i i would say that's something that
i i can't control
um i don't have any control over um you
know those trade deals and whatnot
um you know but for me my job is to
you know help our team win games and you
know help our
offense contribute to the success of the
team
um so yeah well i was gonna buy a to a
dolphin jersey in the off season i
i don't like i just want to make sure
you're still gonna be there though
like should i wait till august here too
well honestly i i'm not too sure um
like i said i you know i can't i can't
control
you know things that i can't control uh
what i can do is continue to work hard
and
hopefully this upcoming season maybe i
get an alabama jersey i'll get it to
alabama jers then i'm safe
uh what are you doing with verizon this
week
uh yeah um i'll be participating in the
new verizon 5g stadium in fortnite
with fans as well as other nfl players
and gamers on february 2nd
and fans will be able to tune in via
twitch and on twitter
at verizon were you allowed to play
video games growing up
i was um oh that doesn't sound like you
you probably had to sneak
to play video games well school days
i i i wasn't able to you know weekends
depending you know if i if i did good
throughout the week with
football practice and whatnot and you
know as well as football games then i'd
be rewarded
by being able to play the game do you
have a curfew
back at home now with your parents
uh no i i never had a curfew with my my
parents
only certain times of my life
when's the last time you were grounded
by your parents
oh i i wouldn't say i was ever grounded
um yeah yeah i just got things taken
away
like i couldn't do certain things well
did you get a timeout or you know like
like your dad said go to your room
no i i never i never got timeouts
only time i've got time out was when i
was in kindergarten in first grade
oh i'm sure what you did was so bad
yeah hey um good luck with verizon and
it's always great to
to uh see you tell your parents i said
hello and uh
good luck with this off season will do
thanks dan appreciate it that's a
tuatongavilo
joining us on behalf of uh verizon 5g
the uh fortnight 5g stadium in fortnight
tomorrow night
and uh fans will be able to tune in via
twitter and twitch
at verizon verizon 5g
seven camera angles with the verizon 5g
super stadium in the nfl